[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll get to your phone calls coming up
best and worst of the weekend i
mentioned we're a danette down
that's up for debate mclovin is not with
us today he's in philadelphia's on the
movie set adam sandler has a new movie
it's a basketball movie plays a scout
for the philadelphia 76ers and he's
looking for this star in europe and he's
kind of trying to salvage his career and
i already shot my scene with uh sandler
that was a couple of weeks ago yeah i'm
a club
is mcglovin playing like the uh the
white power forward for the opposing
team what does he what's his role no no
he's a reporter porter yeah yeah
both are stretch but uh
mclovin joins us now all right
what role do you play you're a re a beat
reporter
well
i actually am not totally sure i'm
either a print reporter or an on-camera
reporter because it's a bit of a gaggle
reporter gaggle how many reporters are
in the scene with you
uh multiple i it just had multiple
so have you
have you met with the director have you
met with sandler i haven't met with
anybody i'm stuck in my hotel room i
asked if i could show up on set at 7am
because i wanted to you know knock it
out
and they keep pushing it back a little
bit yeah so i'm in my hotel room yeah it
doesn't work that way all right do you
want to rehearse your line
yes no i have to change the line so i
don't give away any plot there no no no
no no there's no plot to give away it's
not this one this is like the difference
no this is like no yeah no all right so
i changed the line a little okay um
i
i'm gonna honor paul crew from the
longest yard which also co-starred you
the line is coach crew how do you feel
about getting into the championship okay
so i'm gonna be a reporter okay so i'm
coach crew your coach crew okay
coach crew how do you feel about getting
into the championship
um
let me do it again
coach crew how do you feel about getting
into the championship
todd what do you think
it sounds a little like he's reading off
a cue card okay satan okay
yeah i think it does a couple more times
loosens up a little bit and just like
you know go back to your throwback days
andrew of uh being a pool reporter in
the locker room and you gotta get a
question in
yeah
okay but i think it's gonna get worse
not get better because he's going to go
to the set and now you have sandler
there a bunch of reporters
it's a big deal the cameras are rolling
and you're going to tighten up a little
bit yeah so how do i loosen up
you can't
hear each word you say
because you don't speak that way
just do it in a way that you would
normally speak when you say coach crew
how do you feel about getting into the
championship
not coach crew how do you feel about
getting in the championship
it's almost like you're enunciating
every word think about every word yeah
yeah here's the one of the problems
you're really good and i'm not so that's
going to be a little bit of a you know
they have an expectation i watched you
film your lines the other day and i'm
like oh my god dan's a natural at this
me not so much and back when i did have
to be a pull reporter i was terrible i
could barely get the word that i was so
nervous like i had to interview pat
riley once and no air got through my
system because he was so intimidated
but i have a gift for the director who's
a philly fan okay
okay
well show and tell with mclevin so this
is on camera this is a ball that i got
in 1984
at a 76ers fan event and it is signed by
the entire 8476ers
including
dr j julius irving wow wait why are you
giving this up
well i don't know if i'm going to give
it up but i'm going to show up on set
and show sandman and the director to
sort of ingratiate myself like
you know like oh i'm like i'm part of
the spirit of because there's a lot of
76ers in the movie it's like a kind of a
76ers movie
who is is anybody else in your scene
other than sandler and a bunch of
reporters well the player uh uh juancho
hernan gomez is in the scene okay uh and
another reporter a philadelphia reporter
named anthony gargano okay long time
reporter and that's about it there's no
uh you know in the in the movie there's
all sorts of nba all-stars and i was all
psyched to meet all them and they're
they're not going to be on set
no
no and i think lebron's company is
involved with sandler in this movie yeah
i mean i expected to meet lebron that's
not happening either i don't think so no
yeah not uh in fact i don't even know if
sandman's gonna show up he might just
sort of have a body double for my scene
because i don't really talk to him
so uh
yeah it's uh i actually the less famous
people the better because as you noted i
am really nervous yes paulie dan any
chance uh mcglove would be better if he
uh got some props maybe like a hand
recorder or a notepad and pen and or
maybe even took his glasses off so he
wasn't so mclovin he was a new character
i do have an old tape recorder that i
don't have any batteries in uh and a
reporter's notebook i i actually
prepared all that i went to uh went to
the drugstore just last night
so i i do have props but i don't know
what they're going to do because you get
to set and everything changes right
yeah and i wouldn't
be uh adverse to requesting a mustache
because sandler was always putting a
mustache on me because he thought it was
funny but you know you might do that
then it then you may get into a
character as opposed to thinking that
you're andrew mclove and pearl off
junior the third but i did i had a
mustache when we shot when i was the
boom operator i don't want to be
typecast as the mustache guy yeah that
didn't go well when we were in the
prison
no but actually what the what i had
there was todd was so bad that it helped
everyone all the other damn that's look
good so i need a todd because now i'm
the top
well good luck we're all counting on you
we we hope you do well
but
i just want to make sure you don't
listen to every word you say
because when we were filming something
and i said make love you don't say
anything just walk
you couldn't walk because you were
thinking about walking on camera
let me try the line one more okay all
right
coach crew how do you feel about getting
into the champions no no no no no no no
no
coach crew how do you feel about getting
into the championship
it's a little better
coach crew how do you feel about getting
into the championship
how about
coach well it's actually not
that's a that's a made up line because i
didn't want to give away the plot oh you
stop
you're not gonna give away the plot it's
beau cruz is the name of the character
how do you feel about getting into the
championship
okay but that's not what actually
happens okay
wink wink
you can't see the wink on radio can you
keep us posted mclovin dan i just don't
want to ruin your movie career i promise
that is my only goal no you you can't if
i haven't done it after what 22 films
with sandler you're not going to do it
all right thanks dad all right that's
mclovin live from philadelphia on the
adam sandler movie set yes tom i think
they got to consider he's got to
consider going with a contraction like
how's it feel like you were trying to
encourage him to talk like he would
normally talk when you go how do you
feel as opposed to how's it feel would
sound like more like you would actually
say it that way
if todd is giving advice
i know you agree with website though
that that's part of what the hearing of
every word how do you feel that's pretty
good advice though
that is that's pretty good how does it
feel to play in the championship rather
than how do you feel playing in the
championship game that's pretty good how
do you feel playing in the big game yeah
that's how it's going to come out with
mcleven